I feel like I had heard you maybe give
little dribbles and drabs here and there
maybe make a comment here there about
your experience on Vanderpump rules but
it wasn't until this Instagram Live
where you really kind of let it all out
how you feeling after deciding just to
talk about it well at that time I had
already gone through my two years of
pain and being in like a dark space I
was in here all those things so I grew I
did some spiritual growth I was in a
better space but I still had a little
bit of um you know pent up just a little
bit of kind of sadness and me from that
fact that I didn't happen to me so when
I spoke about it online it felt like
live therapy I'm saying it's a Candice
I'm sure and then to you the audience um
I felt good because that was the first
time that I felt like people had my back
and that I was being hurt hit the
ceiling for me and made me really want
to run for the hills on Kristen and
stocks he decided they were going to
call the cops on me this is when I quit
like I left the show it was a body bag
but you know tell my truth but I decided
it wasn't gonna do anything from me so I
not do that after you did the Instagram
live did you hear from anybody on the
cast good or bad I did
Lala talked to me actually I had to talk
to her so long and I didn't know if it
was something go well or not because I
know that at least the last thing I
heard about it was the watch what
happens live she made any filling in
there somebody called in and asked how
do you feel about face you know baby and
then she goes whose faith she Mariah
Carey no conversations she had recently
lost her father and I know her father
ready very well so I I wanted to give
her my condolences and then from there
it just went in a very good direction
and she wanted to start over with a
clean slate
also Arianna
Dan me and told me congratulations on my
newborn baby as well so those two have
been very warm I haven't heard from
anyone else just these payments that
they put out on Instagram that was
supposed to be an apology so New York
nor Kristen have reached out to you
personally since all of this came to
light um so I believe Kristin Kristin
daddy and me like last minute
so like when after all the pressure I
think kind of got to her I kept seeing
people say you know apologize apologize
apologize personally
so she DM me and said you know she's
really sorry and that she should've came
forward a long time ago and apologize
personally
well now you hear the news that both
Stassi and Kristen have been fired from
the show when that news broke yesterday
I mean what went through your mind I I'm
not gonna lie first I was like wow like
this is gonna change their lives and I
wasn't necessarily happy about it
but what I was happy about was Bravo
this huge production company taking
taking the time to give a voice back to
the people and say we hear you and that
that's to me what that was is Bravo
saying we're not you know a platform
that's gonna just ignore what's
happening and today in society and all
the injustice that's going on we hear
you and that made me feel really really
really really good because I I didn't
think that it would go that far so it's
a it's a it's a production company and a
network that I can be proud of that will
take a stance on something like that
because that really affected me casting
directors would have to ask me have you
drugged anybody before
how about anyone before and sometimes
you know you won't get casted for things
like that because they have that that
worry that that's something that you did
so that was something I was attached to
for two years and my family is a very
proud family and I felt so ashamed but
probably I couldn't be seeing that and I
I think they took a stance on that and
I'm happy to hear that MTV is also
following suit listen do you feel like
that it was two years too late because
again you said this happened in 2018 do
you feel like Lisa Vanderpump closed her
eyes to it and maybe she should have
fired Stassi then um I wish even if she
didn't let them go I wish she would have
let them know it was an issue Nick
let them know that she had a problem
with it because they all look up to her
they have relationships with Miss
Vanderpump I necessarily didn't have a
real relationship with her but I had a
very fake respect for her and what she's
done and the terrible things she does
eventually pulls her own West Hollywood
LGBTQ in the dogs and human festival so
I expected you know for her to have this
as a concern for her as well and
unfortunately it just she just looked
past it but um or maybe she didn't maybe
she didn't know about it I don't know I
was gonna say did she know about I mean
because you also said that Britney
Cartwright called you nappy headed and
that things like that were happening I
mean we saw on the show kind of the
reaction after the incident with you and
Jax we saw the fallout from that didn't
know any of this did you ever tell her I
mean you were close with her son weren't
you yeah yes she knew about the fighting
and the ongoing me and Brittany because
to be honest with you I think she knew
about the incident between me and Jax
before filming even started she's a
pretty structure I knew that she did
something about it from what from my
understanding what I was told but did
not be had a comments me the the podcast
Lisa doesn't have time for access but
once she is aware that that's when I
would expect her to kind of like have
something to say about it to help them
this is her platform as well so what
they do also is a reflection of you know
her stage and what she's bringing out to
the public so I mean there's maybe
there's still time I mean maybe she
won't make a statement I don't know
Brittany says because there were there
was a backlash against her as well she
says she never said that that she never
called you that that that never happened
I'm glad that because I would love to
air dry sex I've been getting questions
saying if I ever apologized to her
because that was a that was big thing
for me to do I'm a kind of person where
I'm always going
admit when I'm wrong I've always said
that the military my 8 years of service
has taught me that my parents have
taught me that so when it this did
happen Sheena called me I think if they
were filming in the background I'm not
sure
okay here's Ricky in the background
screaming and I'm like Britney I was
wanted you to know that I wanted to talk
to sleep person if you ever have time
can we just talk cause I want to
apologize to you and then at this time
she still upset as she should be upset
but she's screaming and saying like
calling me names to be word and things
like that but I'm holding it to company
and I'm still apologizing I'm trying to
stay calm because I knew that I hurt her
so I'm taking you up taking this time to
take the verbal attacks and then I tried
getting to apologize and then I hear her
call me you know and that be I did hope
so
I'm still a human being at the end of
day I do have a temper
so that's not I decided I'm gonna get
out the phone before this gets worse and
I hung up I can only apologize so much
but I don't think she was ready to
receive me at these times that I
apologize
I still hope that she can find it in her
heart to move forward from that and
accept my apology because it was it is
heartfelt it is this year but once it
gets the name calling and talking about
the texture of my hair that's something
I don't want to change I'm very proud of
I just I can't I can't give you any more
of my spirit at the end of the day I
have to move forward but let me ask you
this when you first heard Stassi saying
on that podcast the things that her and
Kristen had done and the fact that they
tried to get you arrested for something
you did not do myself was like a cry
again this time oh it was very painful I
wasn't I was in a very I was in a very
bad spot cuz I had never experienced
that kind of building before I just I
was just getting over the bullying that
I was getting from an offense what to
put me for in Brittany and I was trying
to before with my life and then I got
the call to them to me they they were so
excited they had nice and then I get
this boom like in my face saying that
they're trying to pretty much destroy me
especially dealing with the cops cause I
I have a
I've had kind of affair but a police
phone enforced me because of all the
things that's happening and at that time
what I heard about when they called I
remember that night because I had seen
one of the girls at moose bellows it's a
nightclub so I'm like wow the cops that
came at night and it's suspecting me to
be a woman that would drug people like
date rape drug them they would not have
come any domestic let's talk about a
kind of way they really really wanted me
to go down so bad so one that did not
work for them they call they tried to
contact the military they try to have
the military also arrest me or take me
down as well because they thought I went
AWOL not knowing that I had honorable
discharge papers that showed that I had
done my 8 years of service for my
country so they try to take that from me
too
and then when that didn't work they said
the night of the scandal when it all
came out that night is Sheila's birthday
party
Jack's Carla went missing out of his
home they said I was the person that
went into his home and did grant that
auto like I went it broke into his home
restore his car so they said so much
that it was it was hard to take in and I
was really numb at that moment cuz it
was so it sounded like a movie no I'm a
really bad movie but faith if I'm not
mistaken didn't Jack say that same thing
didn't he publicly also say that you
were wanted for grand theft auto I think
I saw it on his Twitter that you were a
wanted felon that you had been drugging
and robbing people didn't he say that -
he did he did I didn't see it till later
on because I was trying to sell it far
away from her as possible um but I
somebody said to me and I ain't seen it
and you be fired - I think he's probably
had more more terrible things to say
than these two young ladies I got emails
and he and some ladies from different
shows I believe one of them was a
fiancee show 90-day fiance or something
like that show where he attacked her
husband saying you know her husband
she's up she's a white woman in a black
and she attacked her black husband yes
his black features he's said very very
mean things to new cast members he did
not receive me and Lala Kent very well
we first started he said very many
things to us as well later on
apologizing because it seems like he
continues to get away with everything he
does and I'm not sure why especially at
his age it's not like he's doing this as
a young adult as a kid and just you know
making these little mistakes young
people sometimes do he's a grown man and
he's society this is a life he wants to
live and I feel like Lisa definitely
needs to tell him he's wrong and not
just in a show wig she doesn't the show
she needs to really reprimand him off
the show as well so I assume you do
think Jack should be held accountable
his part in this as well have you heard
from Lisa at all nope no I reached out
to her daughter oh I want to say a year
ago I emailed candor a year ago and I
reached out almost she got my email um
but I reached out and I just said no it
was I think it was prefer her and Lisa I
would love to sit down to talk with you
guys also this is the better chance to
try to get ready to hear my apology
because that's something I really wanted
her to hear even after this record um I
wanted her to hear that for me because I
don't want to go through life or her
thinking that I just didn't think I was
just I wouldn't her to know that and no
one fish back out to me I feel like you
know their lies are looking forward and
you know their shows we're looking
forward and they just didn't care about
me
and that goes to show that I don't think
I would have gotten apology but those
boats had those throw had this now to
come out I went to that privately and I
said hey girls
well you said about me let me hurt my
feelings straw in my life I do not think
they would have cared so you don't think
what they said was since their apology
was sincere you think it was for show
and for public to try to save themselves
I can only I can only say what I would
have done when I hurt somebody I want to
reach out to them and let them know as
many times as I can that I want it I
want them to hear me and hear my apology
sincerely and I
I think their statements with Lewis was
I think it was uniform one within one
second of each other when they were
released very similar statements I
believe in a Christian so even though my
comments were racially training it's
like it's so biased like you guys don't
even know how I felt about it to say
that you don't know how I go there how
my family felt sir
my black friends my black cousins my
[ __ ] all of my people we then take that
racially because it was racial profile
you knew it wasn't me I think my mark
bingo was a neat so I I don't know I I
don't think I couldn't receive it I did
receive it as what it was and that I
received at the statement do you think
the show should be canceled um no I
think the show is a great great idea I
just think that maybe they could put
people out there that could you know
give a voice to people and be more
relatable to people of not color
something because there's no people of
color on a show I think I think it needs
to be revamped and it needs to be done
right I mean as we see now there's two
people on that show that also has races
between racial backgrounds and it just
goes to show that they're just not being
bed it correctly I don't think they're
just putting people on how to look um
who can make a really good show but it's
more than that and I believe Vanderpump
is it's really fun to watch if they can
just be casted maybe it had people on
there that actually have some depth and
um you know just just maybe just not be
a racist
[Music]
you